you
every day I face frustrations in the
micro picture you know it's hard to
delegate staff there is a shortage of
operational management skills and so and
then the infrastructure the electricity
but the macro picture is still moving
ahead and it's moved ahead much faster
than anyone had anticipated it really
has over the past 23 years and so we
have to keep that momentum going
my name is Tara Kirko i was born in yema
but educated in the UK pursued a career
in investment banking and finance and
towards the end of 2010 i came back to
my country was caught up in the reform
process and have stayed since
there are fantastic entrepreneurs in
this country and they have had to
overcome real tough challenges financing
issues the lack of a banking sector the
lack of international trade and finance
sanctions have been imposed and yet
they've been able to build successful
businesses whether its food and beverage
chains whether it's modern retail group
supermarkets the best that niama can do
is not to be fearful of 2015 and the
opening of our markets but who actually
adapt as quickly as possible to embrace
it
vindhya we have 60 million people that
creates a potential for a competitive
manufacturing base it is also the
potential for an attractive consumer
market if you open all doors and not
keep things in check within the realms
of the common market then your local
economy and businesses can can suffer
for it you need that combination of
overseas experience and expertise but
local practicalities and local knowledge
and local expertise as well you really
do need that combination the government
and the opposition has taken the courage
to engage with each other and have given
this space and it is now down to us to
fill that space and also engage
you